Speaker 1: There is a video clip I'm going to play
for you here of Maria BARTIROMO, a Fox News host
who has gone from pretty damn good financial
reporter 20 years ago to conspiracy theorist
trump brown noser suggesting on her sunday show
yesterday that Joe Biden is being fed drugs in
order to function and that Barack Obama and Joe
Biden may have known it and helped to cover it up
and asking who is really running this
White House? It's quite a theory,
I must say. And during the clip I'm going to play
for you, if you're watching, you'll actually see
them put up a four box graphic of the people they
suspect might really be running the White House,
might really be in charge. We're supposed
to believe that this is a news channel.
This is supposedly a news program on FOX, not an
opinion show. All right. Let's take a look at it.
Speaker 2: Congressman, there
were signs that Joe Biden and.
Speaker 1: Actually let me just even add before it
before we do this, Maria BARTIROMO is interviewing
Ronny Jackson. Ronny Jackson is Trump's former
doctor who claimed Trump is six three and weighs
£239. That's who's being interviewed for context.
Speaker 2: Congressman, there were
signs that Joe Biden was declining during
the 2020 campaign. I mean, let's face it, he
stayed in the basement the whole time during
during the campaign. So who knew what when?
Are they hiding this and feeding him drugs just
to allow him to function? I know he goes home to
Delaware a lot more than any other president.
Speaker 1: So shocking that he's in Delaware
more than other presidents, huh?
Speaker 2: I guess my question is,
what did Obama know? What did Joe Biden
know? And who's running the White House
right now? And are they covering off for these
a mental there could be a cover up here issues.
Well, that's the big question everybody's asking.
Who's really pulling the strings? He's running.
Speaker 1: Everybody's asking this, guys.
I mean, listen, Ronnie Jackson's telling.
Speaker 2: You country right now. We don't
really know the answer to that. We don't know
if it's Susan Ross or Ron Klein or if it's
Joe Biden or who it is. But somebody else
is doing this. They're doing exactly what you
said. They're rolling him out a specific time.
Speaker 1: And by the way, they
have this graphic immediately ready.
So it's very hard to believe that they had
a graphic ready with the exact people that
Ronnie Jackson mentions putting up this four
box. Is it really Susan Rice running the White
House? Is it Ron Klain, Brian Deese or Joe Biden.
Speaker 2: During the day? He's got good days and
bad days. Good, you know, and whether or not they
have him on drugs, I don't know. There are drugs
out there that can increase your alertness and
your memory and things of that nature, you know,
and cover stuff like this up temporarily. So
I'm sure some of that's going on as well. But
we don't know because his position has stood up
and took the questions that I took when I was
Trump's position and answered those questions.
Speaker 1: Now, it's interesting how Ronnie
Jackson says, we don't know, but it does
seem that that's what's going on. I mean,
he has no knowledge of it. It's not actually
known. But he believes that it is going on. He
says it. It must be. It is what's going on. We're
supposed to believe this is a news channel. Now,
aside from the level of irresponsibility in this,
I want to mention one other aspect of this entire
Joe Biden thing. Now, you all if you've been
watching this, my show, you know, I've said
the 2022 and 2020, Joe Biden are not 2012. Joe
Biden. Joe Biden humiliated Paul Ryan in the 2012
debates, ran circles around him. Had a rapidity
and facility with the facts and arguments. That
is not where Joe Biden is right now. Joe Biden's
nearly 80 years old and that would be common,
common if not typical of someone his age. But
there's a couple different things going on. First,
the level of total irresponsibility on what are
supposedly news programs. Now, there has been
speculation about Joe Biden, which I engage in
as well, on opinion programs. And there has been
speculation about Trump as well. But Fox claims
to be news and think back to when Trump got out
of his plane and his car was right in front
of him and he just wandered off and had to be
brought back by Secret Service when he was sitting
across from Rudy Giuliani and said, Where's Rudy?
And looked around when he said he wants to get to
the origins of the investigation, when he referred
to his himself as Trump instead of Trump, when
he referred to Barack Obama as Obama, when he
talked about the Drac boxes and. Wait, I could
give you that. Fox was silent. Fox was silent.
So there's also that hypocrisy. And then lastly,
when they talk about Biden was in his basement.
If Biden was in his basement and
suffering from cognitive decline,
doesn't it make it even more humiliating
that a guy suffering from cognitive decline
who didn't leave his basement got 8 million
more votes than the sitting president? Now,
their counter would be while those numbers were
fake. So now you've got two conspiracies. You've
got the cover up of the cognitive decline
and the theft of the election. At some point,
we have to say, guys, that's it, that's it. It's
too far. But they don't even seem to get get how
humiliating it is for Trump to have lost. If
those indeed are the situations everyone is
asking this. Ronny Jackson says, wait, they are.
That's news. Fox News, which they claim to be.